as a dietitian these are the three
healthy foods I refuse to buy right now
number one lettuce there's a reason why
so many restaurants are dropping salads
on their menu right now it is expensive
as so while I love my salads I'm
probably going to be sticking to
stir-fried and roasted veg number two
berries I love berries but I live in
Canada and we haven't seen a local Berry
in like six months so they're either
coming from like California or Mexico
and they kind of taste like so I'm gonna
be sticking to Frozen and try to focus
on things like apples and pears and
finally kale I just don't like it like
unless I'm drowning it in Caesar
Dressing the bacon bits and croutons I'm
not that jazzed about it sue me you know
what I always say healthy food is only
healthy if you actually eat it and Hill
is more likely to sit in my fridge and
wait what healthy foods are you avoiding
right now leave me a comment below